he's vasil bodnar he's joining us live
from ankara ambassador good to have you
with us on the al jazeera newshour so
officially as we're hearing from our
reporter turkey is not really releasing
any information tell us what could be
going on behind the scenes right now we
know that you are hoping that the turks
detain the ship but are they giving you
any sorts of guarantees that they're
actually going to be doing so
good afternoon so uh now
really the procedures are being
conducted so uh it is interagency
communications and uh the decisions
should be adopted i believe today
so uh the we presented the whole
documents including the court decision
and request from the prosecutor general
with regard to this case
so turkish side have all full evidences
about the uh illegal transfer of grain
from occupy territory of burdens from
our port and now we believe that it
should be arrested and uh all the
investigation should be going on
according to the request of our
prosecutive general let me let me just
that is not about guarantees
just just
you said that uh this is illegal i mean
can you tell us um according to the
information that you have
where this cargo actually came from and
and how it was obtained
so on the sea of oslo there is uh port
berdansk which belongs to ukraine but
now is temporary occupied by russians
and according to information we possess
this ship
uh which is called djiboc it was uh
transferred there at the end of june
and uploaded with the grain taking from
the different regions and storages
around the
uh district of verdansko around it and
it was shipped to
port karasu also under the document from
port of paradise so previously we have
the cases when russia have been actually
presenting falsified documents bringing
the grain from occupy territory of
crimea to turkey but with the russian
documents which was that the information
that uh they came from russia with
russian port and russian grain but now
it's different and this is a legal
ground for
arresting and investigating all the
cases because it's clearly violation of
ukrainian sovereignty even by the
documents
okay and um
did the ship you mentioned karasu a
moment ago did the ship intend to
actually unload its cargo in that port
of karasu or was it going to continue
its journey south through through the
bosphorus to perhaps other destinations
what information do you have on on its
actual journey
no this ship is
stuck in this port or let's actually
very close to the board
and the customs authorities as i was
informed uh detained him for the time of
investigation because
this ship couldn't let the port go and
couldn't enter and upload because uh it
is still uh unknown uh i mean still the
procedures are unknown for me but uh i
was as i was informed correctly that
there will be an investigation and after
that it will be a decision so i believe
that this investigation should take
place this day today so so you're still
unclear whether its final destination
was was turkey itself or it was
continuing it was
according to the documents the final
destination was sport karasu
so now it stays very not far from this
port waiting for uh its destiny
but as i is informed it should be
checked and then uh it's not let's say
detained then it will be checked and
we believe they should be arrested but
the decision is in turkish side
so
the results of the investigation we
expect are today do you have uh some
sort of timeline are you being told by
the turkish authorities when they will
give you a final decision and how
prepared do you think they really are to
take action against the ship and the
action that you are calling for
yes i feel full readiness of turkish
site to assist us
and uh i wouldn't speculate about the
timelines because it depends on all the
procedures which need to be passed here
but we believe we are in the good way
and
we believe that the decision will be
adopted as soon as possible after the
inter agency consultations which should
be conducted uh this today or maybe
tomorrow but i believe today
okay um well i have you with us
ambassador let me ask you about what's
happening on the ground in in ukraine
because as you are very well aware just
uh 24 hours ago lucichchansk uh was uh
had fallen to the russians it had been
their focus for for a while now what do
you think this means for the the donbass
region and is the battle for dumbass
over in your opinion and do you fear
that
no no it's not over you know it was not
encircled man it was just withdrawal of
forces because there was no possibility
to cap this city
for us actually the main task is to to
keep the armed forces alive
to continue struggle and defeat the
enemy and also to possess losses for
them because uh still we feel lack of uh
different sophisticated weapons like
artillery and mother s
which does not allow us to make a
country balance for them so that's why
they have superiority and it's also very
heroism for ukrainian soldiers which in
this circumstances in this terrible
situation have been defeated defending
their opposition maybe for more than two
months because these attacks uh have
been started after the regrouping of
russian forces which were withdrawn
forcefully uh from the territory around
uh kiev uh chernihev and sumer and now
they are trying to concentrate more
attacks on on the on the on the bus
region
but uh defense of ukrainian forces
they're very effective and even
withdrawal from the city of several
donetsk and
this chance it does not change
strategically the situation so the line
is kept i mean the front line is kept we
are still strong on the on the fields
and we continue to receive the
assistance from the from our partners
abroad and we believe that we would have
enough capabilities to uh
counter attack
as soon as we will collect necessary
armed forces for being strong enough to
start this activity so is ukraine then
still banking on weapons from the west
to be able to uh turn the tide as you
say and go on a counter-offensive in the
eastern regions at least
yes exactly so now we need to rearm our
armed forces and fill it with the
necessary equipment for
counter-offensive because
we
we try to talk to russians and i was
also participating in the talks in
istanbul and there were some
arrangements but as you see they uh just
neglect these previous negotiations and
they try to push their own agenda with
the new occupation new killings and even
new harassments of this uh by these
terrorist attacks so turkey uh
turkey is helping us in this regard
trying to negotiate on the uh terms of
mediations etc but uh it all depends on
russians because it's clear
unwillingness for them not to sign a
peace record not to stop the war but to
continue capturing new territories and
terrorize our population that's their
ambassador vasil bodnar we thank you so
much for giving us the time and speaking
to us from ankara thank you
thank you very much